hello everyone i'm chinen cho from
harvard
this is the talk about our project on
content meets the minimum circuit size
problem
and this is a joint work with a night
height jayu and razer
so this
work is about studying content
computation and complexity through the
length of meta complexity
so you might ask what's meta complexity
in short it is the complexity of
complexity so we're trying to study the
content computation complexities through
the
length of complexity of complexity
and to be more formal let me first start
with uh what's the concrete definition
of meta complexity
especially let's start from the
classical setting
so meta complexity study the complexity
of computational problems about
complexity
so what do i really mean
so maybe the most uh like a familiar
complexity measure for people is the
circuit complexity
it is like giving you maybe a boolean
function i ask you about like what's the
size of the smallest size of a circuit
that can compute this boolean function
and this corresponding problem is
exactly called the minimum circuit size
problem
and there can also be other complexity
measures like common goal of complexity
basically then this is asking something
like related to like turing machine
and for today our focus will be on the
circuit complexity size namely the
minimum circuit size problem
and let me start with formally define
what's a minimum circumstance problem
so to minimize circuit size problem mcsp
the input is the truth table of unbid
boolean function and the size parameter
s the output will be yes if there is six
a circuit of size at most s for this
boolean function f otherwise we will
require to ask output node
so note that the input length here
actually is 2 to the n and sometimes
people denote it as capital n
so that we can basically allow like
rounding time to be like the probably 2
to the n which is like 2 to the one
and
the first observation is that actually
we can show mcsp is in
p
and the reason is very simple as follows
so the input is the truth table of the
your boolean function which is of length
2 to the n
and the weakness
for the input will blend the
circuits of size at mode s
for this uh truth table
and the verifier can simply like run
through all the possible inputs and
check bit by bits on the truth table
and verify whether this is circuits
indeed compute our boolean function and
note that the running time basically is
like
big o 2 to the n times s which is
probably uh 2 to the n time which is the
polynomial over this length of the input
so this is saying that mzsp is indeed in
numpy
but surprisingly
this probably is the uh best
unconditional results uh like uh like
people have known like the easiest
unconditional language and if you want
to show mcspace in p
or mcsp is mp hard it seems uh it turns
out to be uh like surprisingly difficult
and lots of evidence have shown that to
either show mgs pcmp or showing ncsp's
mp house through on standard techniques
actually will result in some surprising
complexity results
so this is saying that this should be
not expected to be easily solved
moreover maybe even more surprisingly
there's even a conjecture called purple
uh conjecture this is saying that the
best uh conjunction conjunction in that
the best way to solve ncsp actually is
by blue force
and this is indeed actually the current
best algorithm
no one have yet come up with an
algorithm better than brute forcing
algorithm to self and csp
okay so so far we have introduced this
mcsp as an example of
classical meta complexity
but you may ask why care like white and
csb is important
so it turns out that mcsp is somehow is
like in the center of a complexity
theory it has lots of connection to
other subfields for example circuit
complexity
people have shown that if you can have
some upper bound for mcs and csp
it will imply some surprising circuits
or bonds
and also it has connection to learning
theory
connection to average k cons every case
of complexity and cryptography
so here i won't uh dig into the details
uh or of all connections because uh
they themselves each tiger is a very
interesting on its own
and the point here is just want to tell
to convince you that ncsp at is in the
classical setting indeed like is a
central object in complexity series it
has so many connections to all other
fields
and yet this is exactly because of this
importance of ncsp in the classical
complexity theory
it motivates us to think about like what
will happen when quantum meets and csp
so in the rest of the talk i'm going to
start with some basic result definition
and results about like
how to define
mcsp in the content setting properly
and then i'll go with uh like a bird eye
view on results actually we showed lots
of uh like interesting property about
the ncsp in the content setting but we
don't have time to go over all of them
in this show talk
so i'll just first give you a broad eye
view on the results
and then i'll like use some highlights
to tell you about some special
properties that only appear in a common
setting that is quite interesting
and then i'll summaries
like
like summarize the talk and give some
future directions and open problems
so definitions and basic complexity
results
so um
maybe let's first
go back a little take a step back think
about like what kind of computational
problems like in the quantum world are
we studying
so in a classical setting we talk about
boolean function
but it turns out that in quantum setting
the most natural uh computational
problem actually it's like unitary
transformation
and in short like for quantum circuits
it computes naturally computer unitary
transformation
by like applying lots of content gates
and then all together compute the
unitary transformation on their inputs
and usually people were divided into two
parts yeah they are in two tubes indeed
like fed by x1 to xn yeah like the super
one variables
and
there's also ncl qubits which is like o0
and for people who are not very familiar
with uh content theory the introduction
of ncrq is exactly because uh unitary
like content computation is reversible
so if you don't allow like extra qubits
actually the computational space in your
corner circuit is limited
so basically you can think of ncr cubits
as some extra register you can play
around with
so given this kind of content circuit
setting
there are actually three natural types
of computation problems we can we can
talk about
so first maybe it's our favorite boolean
function
but
given that a boolean function is
actually i mean the quantum circuit is
not naturally computing boolean function
so the way we say a common circuit
compute boolean function is actually
talking about we measure one of the
output bits and with a lot of generality
we can think it is the first bit
and we use whether this first bits the
marginal probability is greater
is it's being one with a higher
probability of being zero high
probability to decide whether we we
think of the output zero one
and then
uh corner circuits also naturally
computes content state
in the sense that we think of now the
input qubits
is always fixed to zero so there's
actually no input
and under like this computation of the
circuits it naturally computes a gate a
state content state
and this content circuit is
corresponding to the computation for
this common state so you can also think
of this as a preparation problem the
goal is to prepare
a content state
by applying some quantum circuits on all
zero input state
and finally yeah unitary transformation
which is the the most natural way to
like let connect circuits to compute
sets
so to properly uh define the
corresponding ncsp we need to i mean be
more specific
and then talk about last thing about
handle the error probability and the
distance between state etc
so it's a little bit messy
and
for the sake of time
i'll start with just talking about the
the the boolean function definition and
for the rest uh i'll
postpone it to like let you read the
paper unknown
so for the boolean function version we
call it the minimum content circuit size
problem abbreviated as mqcsp and just to
remind you that when we say a corner
circuit compute boolean function we
think about like measuring the first
output bit
so in this problem we all have several
parameters
first is the number of nclq bits and
also the completeness parameter and the
soundness parameter alpha and beta
respectively
the uh
input to the uh
mqcsp problem because this is uh for
like the boolean function
so the input is also truth table of
unbid boolean function
as well as the size parameter s
and the goal now is become slightly
different from the uh the clinical
setting because there are some like
randomness like in the content
computation the common circuits so the
goal now because thick it's
distinguished the yes case where there
is six circuits of size as mos
such that for every input the content
circuits computed with like uh like
alpha like a goodness meaning that the
uh result of the
the boolean function
should be like
after you evaluate with the circuits on
the input
they have this uh they are the closeness
is greater than alpha so this basically
is measure it's like measuring the
probability the marginal probability of
the first
uh output bit to be the value of f of x
and the no case is saying that for any
circuit of size s there is a bad
input x
such that
the probability
of the f x
equals to the uh margin i mean the
output
of the first bit of the quantum circuit
is and small data so alpha and beta you
should think of it as the probability
of like whether the first bit output of
the common circuit
is equals to our boolean function f of x
so notice that this is
already slightly different from the
classical setting this becomes a promise
problem because it could be the case
that there is something going on in the
middle and
in all those situations
and somehow
this is really necessary if you if you
want to make the
connection to other problems and etc to
work yeah this kind of
promise settings is necessary and this
also caused some
like a slightly annoying technical
details to handle
yeah but
as a starter you can always think about
maybe alpha and better like being like
some
some favorite parameter you like say
like a two-third and one so
and
red instead of thinking of it as a free
prompt
[Music]
but uh just a warning that when you read
our paper actually alpha beta actually
kind of subtle in matters at some point
okay so hope now you have a
rough idea on like a definition of mq
csp
so i'll start with explaining some of
the basic complexity result proof
so first we show an upper bound for mq
csp in qcma which is the uh like the
quantum version of the uh like the mp
but now it's like the proof is that
classical and you have a content
verifier
[Music]
what's uh this qcma uh algorithm for
mqcsp
so basically the prover uh can sense the
witness being the classical distribute
description of a quantum circuit of size
s
and m s
to the verifier
and because the quantum verifier has the
content power to simulate the
common circuits so it actually can did
exactly the same things as like the
previous uh mp proof for the classical
mcsp
and
yeah with similar argument you can show
that you just need point number time
yeah but you can also see that we really
need the the content power yeah in the
verifier part so that you can evaluate
and verify
so it is unclear whether people can like
put mqcsp into mp or not
yeah it could be an interesting problem
to study
and on the lower bound sides
we quantize some classical results so
first for in terms of unconditional
lower bound we quantize the recent
seminal results which showed like a
multi-output mqcs mcsps and p-hat and we
similarly show the alt multi output
version of mqcsp is also np-hard
so here i won't define what a multi
output is
it is uh i mean
it is a little bit annoyed to formally
define it but uh also not i mean the
definition also won't be too surprising
so i encourage you to read our paper if
i'm interested in
in terms of conditional lower bonds we
showed some uh
like a result actually by just also like
quantized classical results and by
conditional bank i mean
like if you something like if you assume
uh mq csp is in bqp and then you are
sure like 100 doesn't exist something
like this
okay so now i hope uh uh
i convince you the uh
definition of mq csp is valid like it is
natural and also we can
like show lots of basic results
so next i'm going to give you a bird eye
view on all the results we have
so this is a table
of all the
connections and results we have for like
three different versions of ncsp
uh in in the content setting so the
first category is the mqcsp i introduced
earlier
and there are two versions of ncsp i
won't define uh right now this is for
the unitary version and this is for the
content state version
yeah and to let you uh have a feeling i
mean for bird eye feeling yeah the
different color have a different meaning
so for a blue color it means that
basically it is a direct extension from
the classical and analogous results
and the yellow part is like oh there are
also similar uh result in the classical
setting but in order to prove in a
content setting we need some extra
techniques and uh tools
and for the red results there are like
some new properties that are only unique
in the content settings
so what do we prove uh
basically we uh quantize a lot of the
classical results we have seen like in
the one slice earlier
showing the connection to cryptography
learning theory circuit cerebrum or even
functioning complexity
and the second
like a big category for result is some
lots of reductions um either among
different objects meaning that uh among
like different versions of mcsp in a
common setting or there are some special
self-reduction and search to decision
reductions
and we also show some connections to
some other uh interesting uh
objects called like a slow instead won't
volume such things like tomography at
all so if this doesn't sound uh i mean
doesn't make sense to you it's okay for
now i'll introduce soundplan later but
in order to i mean if you want to have a
better sense on like what we did
concretely i really encourage you to
read our paper and the purpose for this
of this talk is just to give them very
brief overview on how we did
so maybe before i maybe i will go into
like one of few few of the interesting
results later but before doing that
let me first uh tell you a little bit
about like what's the changes and
difficulties in the comment setting
because as we saw in the previous slides
there are actually lots of results are
like the quantization of the classical
results
but some of the extension actually is
not flat direct and trivial
and there are three reasons for that why
it is challenging difficult
first it's like common computation
is generally erroneous and random
so
this makes the definition of like a mcsp
in comments that they actually stopped
like what i mentioned earlier like we
need this uh this kind of a promise
problem setting
and due to the uh like inherent
randomness i mean also like the
randomness is not like classical
randomness that you can fix a random
string and do lots of the argument they
are like this kind of a content content
is going on which is
not so obvious at first glance like how
can you like generalize the classical
techniques to here
but in order to really see that you
really need to go through the
calculation proof which i won't do it
here but i encourage you to take a look
at our paper if you're interested
and the second difficulty actually is
about the introduction of ancillary
qubits so this is also a reason why in
the earlier definition i spent some time
to explain enceladus a little bit
and the reason is that the different
number of ncr cubits actually could give
different circuit complexity
and intuitively this is because you can
imagine if you have more ncr2 bits your
circuits have more register to work on
so potentially maybe the circuit size
can be smaller
in the meantime
the number of anxiety qubits
like also will affect the complexity of
the mqcsp problem
for example if the ancillary cube is
like super linear
actually if you want to do a direct
classical simulation with
the circuits it becomes like super
polynomial time
because now the in the the the size of
the uh
circus in terms of the these size of the
state is like super linear so the
running time will be like 2 to the
something super linear which is super
polynomial of 2 to the n
yeah so i hope here uh
i convince you and see that actually
subtle to the quantum version of ncsp
and finally the third difficulty
actually is maybe surprising at first
glance it is the
subtlety of the various choice of the
content gate set
so it turns out that
some of the results we actually only
know how to start with uh proving with
some certain gate set rather than all
kind of gate set
so in order to generalize to all the
gate set we actually need to invoke
these things called solar bay kitab
steering about like universal
approximation
and applied listening although make
everything work but this also caused
some overhead in circuit complexity
which makes the results a little bit
annoying it's not that looking good in
the sense that different cases now have
like slightly different
parameters and results so all three
types of difficulty although we
basically can handle to some extent
but it also makes the content study of
mcsp a little bit different from the
classical study
right so now
i'll move on to uh talking a little bit
about some uh
more like a surprising and interesting
results in our in our role in our work
in particular i'll focus on the content
state version of the mcsp problem
so previously i only defined the boolean
function version
and now let me define the state version
and we call it smcsp where the first s
stands for content state
so now the input becomes an arbitrary
many copies of the unqubit state and psi
so the reason we have arbitrary you can
think of it as like oh you have oracle
you can keep coloring it will give you a
fresh copy of your content step sign
and we also have a seismometer s and now
the goal is to determine if there is a
circuit s such that it can prepare this
side for you in a sense that
the
the circuits evaluate on all zero input
is very close to psi
and the product with some uh identity
meaning that uh like the first uh um an
unquote output is very close to the side
after you you like a
partial trace the the other part
so note that maybe the first remark is
that here the definition is directly
give you a common state but you can also
define the version where now the input
is just a classical distribute
description of this design
and you want to ask the similar question
again
and the second remark is like uh yeah
actually although i didn't define the
unitary version but with similar ideas
you can also define some unitary version
by like maybe allowing query to this
unitary matrices in certain sense
okay so now uh having this definition of
smcsp in mind we can see some
interesting results we have
and the first i want to talk about is
some content unique reductions
in particular in our paper we show some
search to decision reduction for both
smc sp and the unitary version which is
called umcsp
and we also have self-reduction for
sms smcsp sorry and also some gap
version of mq csp you can actually
reduce this to umcsp
okay so now you might feel a little bit
puzzled but to let you have a feeling
about how to interpret results you can
think of that actually like such due to
decision reduction and self-reduction
are not known
for like classical and csp
so this kind of a reduction actually is
like new and only unique in the content
setting
and to let you have a little bit of
feeling about like
why we can expect this kind of uh
reduction in the
content setting let me give you a like a
brief explain on the key idea
so key idea is like uh because quantum
circuits is like reversible so we are
going to leverage in this kind of a
reversibility problem property
so let me explain to this idea using a
search to decision reduction for sncsp
so just to recall
uh in smcsp the input is a precise s and
you can think of you have lots of copies
of it
and you want to
and for the search problem you want to
find out the circuits c of size and
modes s that prepare this site for you
and for the decision problem you have
like uh you you can query it with a
a
content state and a size parameter and
it will tell you whether there is six
circuits of less size or not
so now for the search to decision
reduction basically we want to solve the
search problem which means that after i
give you a
cornerstone sign
i ask you and with a guarantee that
there is a circuit of size s
and i want to you to give me explicitly
a circus that of size s and prepare this
position
and uh because this is a social decision
reduction so i also allow you to have a
sm csp or decision oracle for you
so how to make this uh search to digital
reduction work so the idea is to
utilize the reversibility and to guess
uh
a state a gate a gate by gate
so you may start with like the first
output
queue bit
and then you guess maybe a gate to b
like g1
and then you query the decision oracle
by applying the inverse of the content
gate g1 to your
input
state psi
and
let the size parameter to be s minus one
so you know that if g1 is a is a gate
that really leads you to a circuit of
size s
yeah then this uh g1 inverse per side
should have a circuit of size s minus
one so sm csp should tell you yes
but if it tell you know it also means
that this g1 probably wouldn't work so
you maybe want to try another g1 and
here i didn't know maybe blue
and if now the decision oracle tell you
yes it means that oh so if i keep
continuing with g1
later on i should be able to come up
with something of size s minus 1
for a g 1 inverse psi
so together i will have a circuit of
size s for our original state of sign
so i can keep continuing doing this
to guess g2 from our gate set
and then invert
reverse it and then query the smc sp
this is your oracle again and it is yes
i can do a g3 and no i mean i just try
another one etc so i can keep going on
going on and i hope
this animation convince you a little bit
on this uh probably should work
and
as a
short remark
actually this is slightly oversimplified
in order to really make it work uh we
need to like consider some error
parameters etc but uh
in a very high level this is the rough
idea and
in our paper you can see how we make it
make every detail work
but
i want to conclude this slides actually
with an open problem
so actually even though we established
like uh this kind of i i mean either
surf to decision reductions of sales
reductions to like the quantum version
of ncsp
but we don't yet know like across the
applications of that and intuitively i
mean it's some new properties that uh in
the classical section
won't have yeah it'll be really
interesting to see if people can find
some applications of this kind of
content unique reductions
so beyond this uh content unique
reductions yeah uh for other for for the
controversial ssp there are also some
other interesting applications that's
very unique to content
for example
one can use the state version as mcsp to
break pseudo-random state and contain a
one-way function so here i won't really
define what does those two mean
i encourage you to read some
relevant uh
parts in our paper if you're interested
in but you can think of them as some
interesting quantum primitive in the
study of quantum complexity quantum
cryptography etc
and the second interesting result i want
to share in this talk
is like we also establish some kind of a
weak equivalent
between
like solving smcsp and estimating the
wormhole value under some like common
assumptions and conjectures
and to see like uh what's the connection
yeah
like uh basically the connection is
following the volume of a wormhole
although i didn't i won't define what's
wrong here
under some uh
like a conjecture called a volume equals
to complexity conjecture by physicist uh
lena sasking
yeah it is conjecture that the volume
will be equals to uh roughly the same as
the circuit complexity of a thermal uh
thermophile double state
and then uh under like assuming there's
a correspondence between like
gravitational theory and the content
theory called ads cft
if we assume this connection
is kind of officially computable
then we can show that we can use smcsp
to like kind of
solve the complexity of the thermal
double state and hence understanding the
estimate can be able to estimate the
volume of a one call
and in the other direction if you can uh
if you are able to estimate the volume
of a wonko we also show that for service
certain subclass of as
msmcsp meaning that now the state is
some state level appear in the content
series from the cft series
this kind of sncp will then be solvable
so that's why i'm told i i said this is
like a weak equivalent because
even you can estimating uh the volume of
vocal doesn't mean that you can solve
the essence people
arbitrary states because those comments
they might not really happen in the
physical reality
okay so i hope so far i give you
i convince you that there's something
interesting going on like the quantum
version of the
ncsp problem indeed has some unique
property and can connect it to lots of
different stuff
so now uh summary and some future
directions
so in this work uh we basically have a
three-step program to study like when
content meets the mcsp problem
so we start with uh defining uh the mcsp
for the boolean functions in the content
setting
and study some basic property and
reproduce a lot of connections to
different subfields in a theoretical cs
and then we move on to study the minimum
content circuits problem for content
objects like common state and
unitary transformation
and then we also talk about something i
completely skipped in in the talk
yeah it is like using content algorithm
and content reductions to start the
quantum version of mcsp or even
classical versions so there are also
some interesting results there
so for all flan i only gave a very very
uh surface surface level of introduction
in the talk
and but i hope i
motivate you enough to take a look at
more details in optics
and finally
i want to tell you that this is probably
just the beginning of the study of
content like mcsp in a content setting
and there are lots of interesting future
direction to explore
so first maybe because we
for the basic complexity result we
didn't push too hard yeah our upper
bound is mostly focused on the quantum
part but it could be the case that
there's there could be some interesting
classical upper bound for example
it could be the case that we can put
some of our
special setting of the content version
of ncsp in mp
and another interesting uh
question along this line is like how to
handle super linear number of ncls
cubits
i briefly mentioned about the difficulty
uh earlier and
in our opinion it is quite uh puzzling
and interesting to think about like oh
if super linear like a number of ncr
qubit actually can be handled similarly
as like uh like linearly uh number of
ncr qubits
and also another interesting feature
directions is to find applications of
the content unique reductions
and
also like uh
for uh
oh yes and also uh like uh the in the in
the previous slides when we talk about
content unique reduction we all talk
about like either the state version or
the unitary version
but for the boolean function version the
mqcsp actually we don't yet know uh is
there are there any like search division
reduction self-reduction
and it could be a case there is because
the common circuit is still reversible
but the difficulty is like uh
the when we do the similar like guess
and verify task it might destroy the
boolean structure of the circuits
because if you remember when we define
mq csp
we like use the first bit like uh
marginal probability to determine the
the outcome but if you like keep doing
our like uh
the guess
guess and
reverse uh trick
it actually might disturb like uh like a
mess up the the structure and it's
unclear like
a direct uh
applications of the idea will work or
not but it also uh could be the case
that with some more ideas you can
actually make the search to decision
reduction work
and next uh like can we
build on more connection to other stuff
in cryptography of other areas
and also
maybe even more connections to some some
interesting uh like area in the study of
common complexity or beyond
yeah so i think
i hope like in in this
in this talk and our paper
i can convince you that uh there could
be some interesting future connections
between like meta complexity which here
we use mcsp as a starting point and
common computation content complexity
so thank you for your attention and i
hope if you have questions feel free to
talk to us offline or send us an email
thank you